so I would love to welcome we have our
Ian
we have Kazuhiro we have David and we
have Lucy thank you so much for joining
us
could you just just to start briefly
tell us a little bit about your role on
the film you've been nominated for so I
was very open and I applied half the
makeup for David and applied the wig and
maintained his hair and makeup on set
great hi I'm David
I was the prosthetics supervisor on
darkest hour and I was brought in to
oversee you know what you see on screen
today of Gary you with Lucy my name is
Carl ooh I did a hair and makeup design
for David or woman yep
hi I'm Arion I designed army pullman
makeup for wonder great i think let's
get straight into a darkest hour clip
and then we can talk more about the face
what to hear about
hardly seems like there's a war on at
all you know I've never written about
sir
I've never killed for bridge I believe I
can boil an egg but only because I've
seen it done and that was quite easy yes
it was I believe we are to meet
regularly once we can afraid how is how
I'm for Monday's thrilling gave it to be
available on Mondays for clock i nap for
is that miss book no necessary I give
you your father my beloved husband the
Prime Minister the Prime Minister
here's true so not buggering it out
collectively we are looking at the
collapse of Western Europe in the next
few days should the public be told
no yet first swing Strauss our old
friends to have wrote resistance
I need not impress upon you a trouble
faced by the Western Hemisphere without
supporting some fishing from Canada
nothing motorized then you could pull
them over the border yourself offices
and you did say that a team of horses
Hitler will not insist on outrageous
terms he will know his own weaknesses he
will be reading one mother lesson be
learned
when well then the something learn how
we more dictators must be wooed appeased
good God given him its privileges before
we learn you cannot reason with a tiger
when your head is in its mouth Belgium
has fallen they will surrender at
midnight France will soon follow suit we
shall not flag or fail we shall go on to
the end
we shall fight in France we shall fight
on the Seas and oceans we shall fight
with with growing confidence and go
extinct in year we shall defend our
island whatever the cost may be we shall
fight on the beaches we shall fight on
the landing grounds we shall fight in
the fields and in the streets we shall
fight in the Hills we shall never
surrender I don't even know where to
begin my questions about Churchill's
face because it's such a amazing
transformative thing to see but let's
start with new technologies what kind of
technologies did you use to make the
jowls alone new technology what we used
is the best very kind of traditional
they're what we try to do a new is more
like artistic execution so the difficult
part was basically like Gary didn't look
like a charger at all it doesn't look
like charge at all so try to figure out
what would be the good balance to make
him look like a charger but at the same
time try not to make him look like
wearing a mask so it had to be good
balance and also for me like a sculpture
bringing a good shape looks like a
charger but because especially a charger
has a little short face like a long face
but Gary is oval so I have to make it so
kind of cuttable create the illusion by
bringing a neck forward and put the chin
higher so I have a shorter face and lots
of those
tiny detail and also create the define
wig to change a whole head shape and
because we had the talk with Gary that
okay do you want to shave your head and
save 20 minutes from makeup time or
spend 10 20 minutes extra time to keep
your hair and so he preferred to shave
his hair yeah that's kind of thing and
you know we had really fortunate to have
David and Lucy they're amazing sweet
people to apply makeup every day because
I was kind of I'm the one who got out
[Laughter]
choose another life so yeah but it was
great so tell me about the fine-tuning
then of the makeup so you've got the
prosthetics on how do you make him look
human how do you make you look human and
well I guess you know it starts off with
the prosthetic pieces you know that are
made to really close max - Gary skintone
and then they're painted every single
day because the PCs can't be reused so I
think the challenge was trying to
because it's over such a short period of
time I think it's over five or six weeks
in history so Gary doesn't change or
Churchill doesn't change over that time
which is I guess kind of good because
you don't have as much continuity to
deal with but you have continuity
because he has to look exactly the same
every time we apply the makeup so the
challenge was making sure the pieces
were pre painted and looked the same
every every day that we applied the
makeup and we did 48 shoot days in the
end plus rehearsal days and camera test
days so there's 61 times he was in the
makeup for and he had to look the same
every time
and the same of the week you know that
Lucy looked after we had five wigs made
that all had to look the same and they
were made in LA and shipped over so
whenever they would arrive Lucy would
have to then match them to the wig that
we already had so he just has to look
the same every time
yes what were the biggest challenge is
about sort of maintaining that
throughout the day of filming probably
because we were a very small team on set
David and I and with the pieces coming
in daily David would spend time painting
them so I would be looking after the
makeup and hair and David to come back
and forth so because there wasn't very
many of us it was I suppose the
challenges was looking after the makeup
and doing the hair checks simultaneously
but fortunately for us Gary is really
patient so he looked he allowed us to
just maintain it all day long and then
when they call checks I could just go in
for the important thing is sort of
standing out no major disasters then and
let's have a look at wonder then and
Arion you can talk us through what you
did for this I mean I'm all my way
through the film it's an incredible
piece of work so yeah let's have a look
I'll meet you right here after school
okay right here
I love you okay - I'll see you later
you hear me
if they stare let them stare you can't
blend in when you were born to stand out
we're gonna have a lot of man-to-man no
I gotta stop here because past this
point is a no dad zone and you don't
want to walk up with your parents
because it's not cool but you're cool I
know I am but technically most dads
aren't so neither of these helmets Hey
two rules first only razor hit once a
class no matter how many answers you
know except for science crush though
check a second I'm gonna feel like
you're all alone all game but you're not
should we lose this costumes are for
Halloween prepare for blast-off
I love you Norwegian have fun
have an excellent maken and Godspeed
your God please make them be nice
can anybody tell me what this word means
anybody know precepts are rules for
really important things like mottos or
like famous quotes or like lines from a
fortune cookie right precepts can help
motivate us they can help guide us when
we have to make decisions about really
important things okay so who wants to
read this month's precept
[Music]
what about you what's your name summer
summer want to give it a shot when given
the choice between being right or being
kind she is kind mister Tishman went out
of his way to tell me how sweet those
kids were and that Julian is apparently
quite the dream no not a dream
is he one of those kids that acts one
way in front of grown-ups and then
another way in front of kids yeah I
guess well I know it's hard but you have
to understand that he probably feels
badly about himself and I want someone
next small you just have to be the
bigger person right right person and
rise above it it's that easy
Arion you're working with Jacob Tremblay
who is just an amazing kid you know the
challenges of working with a child not a
build an adult taught me through those
while everything was different I mean
everything from from just sitting in a
chair his life cast to I mean he's very
small he was 9 when we started but he's
very small for his age I was more like a
6 or 7 year old who the sense of like
how big he's headed and then he was the
lead on top of that and we couldn't lean
on anything because other kids have been
in prosthetics before in films of course
but I couldn't think of one where one
was in the lead role in full silicone
because nothing is is you know his neck
everything is fake
so that was an enormous challenge and on
top of that you're copying something
that's a medical condition that's a real
thing that exists so and then all at one
point production was this hiding well
makeup doesn't work then we're gonna go
fully CG but there's no budget
that so we might not make the movie and
that kind of bothered me you know anyway
rambling on but but the so told casually
about the technologies there must have
been I think I saw quite a few different
structures that you had to use can you
talk through some of the most specific
ones well just to copy the condition
that he has Augie has Treacher Collins
syndrome and they have underdeveloped
cheekbones and ears and and just to kind
of copy that look or give the illusion
that Jacob has that it's it's a very
kind of tortoise like profile if you
will to the sloped off neck and a lot of
scars and the surgeries the nose and
then to pull the eyes down we had a
skullcap out of carbon fiber underneath
the wig and the prosthetics with a wire
system that ran through his eye bags
that we could lock and unlock because I
knew I couldn't glue his eyes down you
know for that long we could shoot it was
nine hours from door to door so by the
time makeup was done we had maybe five
to six hours of shooting if you count
our school and lunch or something so and
then there wasn't a big neck prosthetic
went from his shoulders his chest op his
chin and the forehead with the nose and
then the wig we had three wigs we
rotated am i wouldíve you every day
Treacher Collins gets tend to grow their
hair a little longer because they have
underdeveloped ears so there's no ear
actually that's just it like a little
gear knob and yeah it was just it was
and then of course having the eyes
cooled down it kind of looked not right
it made it look kind of melted or say
you keep saying that a burn victim like
almost so we gave him contact lenses so
if to fill up the bottom of the eye
white well and then he has teeth
slightly yeah upper teeth because he has
a cleft palate so and it's kind of
pushed his upper lip out just slightly
just to carry help that tortoise profile
how did Jacob deal with that that's a
lot it is a lot for any actor
let alone for him so I I wasn't sure if
I could do it but he I said I gotta meet
him first not gonna meet his parents so
he came to the shop and I just needed to
feel his energy a little bit and you
just walked he was so little and about
what and everybody says that name you
know working with this person is great
to work with there's a profession but he
really was great but I didn't know that
about this we had about 40 days of
shooting with him in the makeup and he
doesn't change its it's in like a year
of his life and I knew that you know 20
days in you'll probably have a moment
and he did but luckily the parents were
very very supportive and everybody was
great on that helped them through that
you know this is a question for all of
you how do you sort of where's that line
between having enough prosthetics that
the actor looks like what you need them
to look like and allowing their
expressiveness to come through like as a
lifestyle you know I think it's just the
balance of what is needed and what is
necessary and also the condition of the
act is face skin and you know if act is
young it's kind of easy I mean when skin
is so tight the expression transfer
leading where to the surface but as I
have to get older you know like I'm
getting old and the skin slide around on
surface and if I put a piece on it it
just doesn't move and there's the edge
start to show up so according to the
sometimes we have to decide the where
the edge ends to the area that almost
like kind of a risky you know right in
the center of the cheek and something
like that so it's really depend on the
case-by-case so we have to do a test and
figure out what will be the best answer
David you worked with Gary previously to
work in your darkest hour does that make
a difference do you when you have a bit
more of a connection with an actor is
there more trust there yeah I guess so
it's because when Gary first asked me
about darkest hour and
knew that it was going to be the most
intense job I've taken on it was quite
nice knowing that I'd work with Gary and
when I finished on that it was hit man's
bodyguards that I did and as soon as I
finished I wanted to work with Gary
again straight away because we just got
on so well together we only spent a few
weeks working together but we have a
similar sense of humor and you know
which goes a long way when you're
sitting in a chair for four hours every
day for several months and you get to
see people in you know I guess in their
highs and their lows but just stuff
that's going on in their life and on the
production and stuff like that so I
think it's important to be able to get
on with them similar to why I brought
Lucy on as well you know because I just
knew having worked the gallery that Lucy
and Gary would get on I knew that we
would get on and it just kind of worked
really well so yeah and you know we're
there you know our days were 18 hours a
day you know at least so when you're
with someone that and they have time you
you really want to be how to get on it
yeah there not to be any tension there
was over now and then because it's just
a default job but yeah 99 percent at the
time I think we all got on yeah is there
a particular film that you've seen this
year that you've really noticed and
admired the prosthetics and the makeup
on you know could you kind of see are
you sort of looking at the prosthetics
are you looking at you know what are in
was talking about in wonder you just
sort of I think when a makeups done that
well you watch something and you forget
that it's makeup well hopefully yeah so
but I think as makeup artists you always
watch something and you just scan the
whole time and I think you're just
trained to do that after a while yeah
that the thing with you were you sort of
looking at Churchill's gels going how
did they do they thought oh sure sure
but it's also I can you just enjoy the
work you know
forget that it's makeup and that's I
think a compliment yeah but ya know I
enjoy seeing so many films but yeah
darks that was amazing
I'm gonna open it up to you guys now so
if you have any questions we have got a
mic so please pick your hand up and wait
for the mic to come to you
yes gentleman in the middle here hello
firstly congratulations on all your work
at the nominations I started in the mid
90s at Jim Henson when every all the
prosthetics was shot on on film as
things have moved into sort of 4k and an
HD and so I know dark style shorten film
I'm not sure wonder was not on a film
right an area was wonder shot on the
film I forget it's not HD HD pay so how
much does the has the shooting format
over the years informed your decision
makings in terms of technically well I
remember is the first four four days or
so shooting with with Oggy
we matched the silicone to his skin
stone just help cut makeup time because
again we have only an hour and 15
minutes to get it on him but when I saw
the dailies this type of camera they
were using it was very cool that a lot
of red more red and digital I would say
that pull out and so we up that on top
of that on in case of Oggy
I knew like lays eyebrows didn't work so
they're all individually punched in for
each set every day because I knew that
would show up you can maybe get away
with that on an addled
because it is texture and color and
speckling but not on a kid so just I
guess more the fact that I was working
with a nine-year-old I had to battle
some more I guess but I guess it counts
for them as well you know it's a it it
pushes everybody I would say to you know
pick certain laces or colors but yeah
less makeup be I would say painting and
happy oh and I think it's also the
creativity around lighting as well so as
much as you might have whether it's shot
on film or 4k or a K is what they're
doing there which is insane and you know
on darkest hour if you've seen the
entire film or just for those clips you
can you can see the way they like the
shot is
is really important you know because we
have so much cross lights in to simulate
sunlight come in through a window and
there's just it just wants to pick
everything out whether it's just a stray
hair or whether it's lace or whether
it's an edge or whether it's the sheen
you know the junction between prosthetic
and skin you know all these things
everyone's pushing the boundaries so
people you want to create and these
really nice lighting effects it then has
a knock-on effect to us as well I think
so it's not just the quality of the of
the for kak or whatever it is I think
it's everything you know everyone's just
upping their game a bit yeah even you
saw in some of those shops there it's
and you know we would see the shot list
for the day and it would say close-up of
Gary Reed in whatever he's reading or
something and they do a shot you think
wow that's close you know you're going
well we we we did it that's great and
they say right now let's go in for the
closer and you think I get another
closer and then when they're in the
closer they just keep pulling any of
them closer to the end of the day yeah
of course it's always at the end of a 10
or 12 hour day but you know that's a lot
of pressure when you guys did like keep
that so perfect all the way to be there
yeah well and pressure on Gary to keep
it looking good you know he's so
respectful of about craft you know he he
would sit still in the makeup chair for
four hours and would only move if we
asked him to move he'd be on set he
wouldn't sleep in the trailer you know
lots of people you apply makeup to
they'd fall asleep
and they wake up and there's either the
impression of their iPhone in their face
you know a pillow you know like you wake
up and you get the red line sometimes
you know you get all sorts of stuff yeah
Gary didn't want to sleep because he
didn't want to ruin the makeup and he
didn't want to go through the checks
unless he had to
no he just found if he didn't eat and if
he did eat he just made really small
bits of food and he'd just be really
careful about it so yeah I mean it's a
lot of it it's down to Gary as well it's
not just us looking after everyday it's
him looking after it for us yeah I would
like to worry Gary no he's great
that's often yeah absolutely yes um I
wondered if you could tell me a bit more
about the wigs I was fascinated by the
fact that they were you were flying them
in from you say la what were they
actually made of and how much do they
cost and why do you saw something like
that from okay
so it was made by Bob Chris mirror and
Diana choy and basically the lace we
used was English lace it's a really like
a finest lace we can get and it's
constructed on Gary's head shape and the
hair was baby European hair mixed with
Angola and so it was a kind of final
decision to get that wig from LA so
after we did the test in the film test
as they start to shoot film with test
wig as they finish I cut and dress and
shipped to London and Lucy much with all
other wig and we made a total of five
and it's only lasted ten days of the
shooting because it's a laser so fine
and after ten days we cannot use that
anymore so that's how it was for usually
they charge like $8,000 Wow yes that's
normal now yeah gosh and we've got time
for one more question
there's a lady just at the back row
they're waving at you can see ya
oh let's squeeze two in let's squeeze
two him hi I just want to ask what are
the challenges on working with faces and
skin that have Botox and fillers that
excludes the actor in wonder because
obviously I don't or anything that's an
interesting question eeeh have you
worked on contractual stuff mention any
names of that the challenges on you know
the differences between working on on
skin and faces that don't have Botox and
fillers and then you have actors faces
that have Botox and fillers so I just
answer that one yeah I've worked with an
actress that that I remember we did a
life gasps and then did two pieces for
and then when I arrived on location it
had done something and it wasn't quite
matching up it's very subtle but just
because of the like catching it in the
texture for what she's done
I had to rescale that last last day and
like two days before shooting in the
hotel and remould it and you know but no
I mean they don't always tell you and
there's often contractual agreements
between that they can't do it yeah and
right sorry I can't really answer that
just a lot quick question go on hi
yeah I just to everybody I'm just
curious to know for both wonder and
darkest hour how long did you have from
life cast through to the first day
shooting to perfect the looks that you
both executed I was lucky so we did a
live cast in end of June in 2016 and I
did the first three tests make up three
different versions after two months
after two months after after the life
cast and then defined that version and I
spend another month to do two other ones
and the fifth one was a kind of close to
the final
that was only in LA and shipped that
mode and everything to London actually
mode was shipped to Spain because we had
to hire DDT to run all pieces for the
filming and we did a film test and I
think there was a another we spend a
week between and another film test
before that was a final final I think
eight applications you know cuz Gary
wanted to be in full makeup for all the
rehearsal days which was I guess kind of
good for us because it just gave us a
few days to you know home they look
really and get it signed off so but he
just added another eight applications to
the fifty but we were gonna be time for
film instant for Jacob I think we had
about two two and a half months I came
in and we did two different tests
because we had a lot to figure out with
the helmet and the mechanics of that and
in the hair and in the lens I mean again
just because everything was like I mean
II you know and then iris Culp did some
of the bits when are we forming a ride
to Vancouver for shooting because I
wasn't happy with some of it and that
was it so yeah was it great thank you so
much for joining us thank you to our
wonderful panel
[Applause]
you